I've debated doing this when I was
pinned down by a sniper in Afghanistan
taking my helmet off if that's your last
resort and all you're trying to do is
locate a sniper's position but there's
no way that enemy sniper would have hit
that though my name is Nicholas Irving
I'm a former US Army Ranger Special
Operations Sniper I'm also known as the
reaper for my 33 confirmed kills in
Afghanistan today I'm back again to look
at some more sniper scenes from TV in
film and judge how real they
are I may have a shot absolutely not
she's offhand like there's no support
it's all musling it in to uh make that
shot and that gun oh well yeah that's no
the Olympic
Arms
k23b is what it is that weapon is like
literally accurate for you know up to
like 50 m that distance looks like it's
about at most a couple of hundred yards
put it back in the case and go back and
get a different
one it's not clean repeat I do not have
a clean shot yeah I don't think she had
a clean shot at all in the military a
clean shot would be um you're not going
to wound or injure or kill something you
don't intend to if her Target is one of
those two men that bullet you know it's
a 5.56 it's going to zip right through
the bad guy and potentially
wound or kill the guy she's trying to to
help out or save I say take the shot but
can't take the bloody
shot if I was forced to take the shot
I'll pull the trigger but I'm not going
to guarantee you anything luckily the
train does kind of like come towards her
as opposed to moving left or right that
takes out so much more of the
mathematics behind making a shot when
it's moving closer or away from you it's
all about just aiming above the target
are a little bit below the target as
opposed to you know aiming in front of
it and having that individual
essentially run into the bullet I would
rate it a one like it's just not
happening at
all that little good tactical deep
breath pause you know before the shot
was really good to be more precise you
essentially have to be calm and one of
the easiest ways to calm your body down
or right before shot is to just take
deep breaths and get the blood
circulating I would have got more Square
behind the the rifle as opposed to like
having my legs off to the side like that
maybe got down like in a squatting
stance or on my knees and kind of put my
weight behind the gun that way when
recoils it's kind of more of a straight
back motion and not this motion he's
going to
pretty much get that just because his
body alignment and the way he's holding
the
rifle there you
go yeah I think it was smart for him to
let the vehicle get closer to him
everybody thinks being a sniper we want
the longest furthest shots but ideally
you want the closer ones just because it
makes your job that much easier and it
you know it's almost like 100% guarantee
you're going to hit but with that if I'm
protecting someone and I shoot the
vehicle within you know a few yards from
him the guy is still going to get hit by
the moving
vehicle I don't like that the car just
did a triple axle like 20 ft from the
guy like that's not how that works at
all the only moving vehicles that I've
shot I was a machine gunner and I've
never once made a car flip over normally
they just crash into a wall or crash
into another parked car just roll off
the side of the road into the desert I'd
give it a six the the only thing that's
pulling me back are giving it a less
lesser number is because of the sniper
waiting for the car to get
[Music]
closer I mean as far as being a highly
accurate sniper rifle concealed as a
flute I don't think so there's a lot of
big things on on a sniper rifle that
makes it accurate but the barrel is like
really important and most barrels on
sniper rifles are fluted and floated
there's like no interference between the
barrel and the stock of the gun as to
not like interfere with the harmonics
when it goes off that flute looks like
one continuously long long object it
probably is accurate maybe at the
distances that he's shooting at but I
also don't know what caliber he's
shooting but it's Tom Cruz so it's
probably really
[Music]
accurate I'd give the female sniper the
best position whatever she's in that
little room or the designs on the walls
I think that really gives her an
advantage it almost as like shooting out
of a loophole it's like a tactic snipers
used overseas where you punch a small
hole through a wall or something and a
sniper would back away from the wall and
shoot through that hole to hit an object
outside the guy with the shades on he's
not really in a concealable concealed
position but I guess he's using his
attire to make him least Stand Out worst
position I'd have to say Tom
[Music]
Cruz any sniper rifle can be suppressed
even up to like 50 caliber uh sniper
rifles you're still going to hear like a
noise it sounds like a a clap a loud
clap or if you took a ruler and and
smacked it on a desk unless you use like
subsonic rounds which he may be using in
this instance where I could see nobody
else really hear
anything shooting lights are actually
extremely hard to do like that was one
of our things overseas sometimes when an
assault team is going up on a building
they want the light shot out for them to
make it dark and that's it's actually
pretty tough cuz it blurs out everything
and it's hard to find exactly I guess
where the middle is at I'll give it a
five those shots are are you know
possible but I don't think that this
scenario setup is that realistic
I grew up watching this movie it's like
one of the reasons why I wanted to
become a sniper every sniper you have
your rifle and you have your ghilly suit
what it essentially does is break up the
outline of the human body and mimics or
makes you appear to be brush or foilage
but it's not just the ghillie suit
that's What Makes You camouflage what
you're going to really want to do is put
a bunch of natural vegetation into the
ghilly suit so you look more like the
natural surrounding as opposed to just
the this big pile of of ghillies suit on
the
legs you have the Spotter and you have
the sniper the spotter is the one who's
not pulling the trigger and he's holding
up a or using a spotting scope um
through his it look like a red dot
camera thing or something like that
that's just not what it looks like
either you're going to have a reticle
that mimics are as similar to what the
snipers using these Mill dots or uh
radiant lines that are going to you know
give you your distance and be able to
track with a bullet impacts he's
moving
650 range
me being a sniper it it's like 80 to 90%
of your job is is observation it's
actually really rare that a sniper does
get a chance to pull the trigger most of
our stuff is just relaying information
watching stuff taking pictures and
telling the commanders what's going on
on the ground so you can be out there
for as long as the job
needs I think everything he did there
was just fine looks like he's using like
an M24 sniper rifle could be or
something similar to that a variant but
um like they're good out to like 800 M
and 650 yards like that's not that's far
but it's not that far for like a sniper
and a body shot which is what I normally
aim for was perfect like that's all
you're going to go for at that distance
my only issue would probably have
something soft underneath his uh his
rifle maybe put down a pack or his
backpack or something you know to to
rest it on that helps with the harmonics
and having the rifle bounce and get all
the way from you I give it a seven I was
going to give it an eight but a seven
because the sniper scope and the
reticles and all that stuff just didn't
make any
sense to stay still when you're pinned
down by a sniper it's like almost a
death wish it's just a matter of time
before he's going to figure something
out to make those bullets impact running
zigzag patterns getting out as fast as
you can is probably your best
bet to prevent an enemy coming in to do
what just happened here sneak up behind
you in Sniper school they teach you no
more than like two shot two or three
shots your sniper hide is burnt um you
would want to move ideally to a new
location once you have a good sniper
hide set up the odds of you like getting
out after that second shot third shot
it's it's it's slim but there are
countermeasures to deter people from
entering that sniper hide like for us we
might put up a claymore or some booby
traps or something like that behind us
and even a guy with the machine gun is
usually watching our back
that actually wasn't too bad and it's at
night time with no night vision so I'll
give him that we hit targets at
nighttime um but the distances are
extremely close we had a a sniper scope
that was mounted with a PVS 14 I believe
uh which is a night vision attachment
that goes on the front of your
scope both Bol guns bolt rifles they Jam
all the time especially in like Dusty
conditions that bolt gun when you pull
it back it's exposed to the elements and
it's such a slower process as opposed to
like a semi-automatic where the bolt is
coming back extremely fast so it's more
prone to collect dust and things of that
nature that would cause it to to jam up
man this is getting tough I don't know
I'd give it a six because realistically
shooting at night time like that I can
see you missing that
much I've debated doing this when I was
pinned down by a sniper in Afghanistan
taking my helmet off if that's your last
resort and all you're trying to do is
locate a sniper's position I would have
probably stuck my helmet up like on a
the tip of my gun and dangled it up as
opposed to like throw it I might need
that for later but there's no way that
enemy sniper would have hit that
though
like back in World War II snipers used
to use the trees to hide in and shoot
from and there really is no benefit to
hiding in a tree once they find you out
all they have to do is you know Center
all their guns onto that tree and chop
it down hiding underneath the tree are
like in the the hole of the tree where
some of them get you know hollowed out I
could see that um but I'm scared of bugs
so that's not for
me
as far as taking the shot when he took
it nine times out of 10 if a sniper is
being sent out it's to OverWatch his
guys and make sure nothing happens to
them but if we're already engaged in
targets and we're already being shot at
then anything that's moving on that
opposite end that is a threat or has a
weapon is going to get shot so yeah he
had every right to to pop a few rounds
off at this guy I would have too I'd
give it a nine just because I've been in
like a situation where I baited taking
my helmet off and using it as a
decoy I so I was an onset uh Tech
advisor on this film and also played the
dead guy that he got the radio from
should have won an award for it best
dead guy ever but that sand was real um
we were really like in the desert and it
was brutal it's extremely hard to aim
through we call it a brown out where
it's just like a a semi little I guess
dust storm that rolls to you can't see
anything so he's definitely definitely
not going to be able to make a shot
especially at the distances that he's
going for with that much dust blowing
around of scaring uh his vision give me
back right um I'm not going to say it's
impossible to to take out an enemy
sniper who's hiding among stuff like
that the hardest thing the good sniper
is going to have to do is locate them
from what I remember I recall it being
over a th MERS away which is extremely
extremely far to be conducting a counter
sniper
operation the sound of the rifle that
John Cena is firing in the movie is not
how it sounds in real life like this
sounds like a semi-auto a atic rifle
with like a suppressor on it or
something like that in real life that
gun is just a big thunderous boom a big
bang the way he was shooting in the
movie it's kind of like like it's a
semi-automatic as opposed to him
cranking the bolt back every time and
the sound is
off please tell me you got yeah he was
dead from the get-go like shooting in an
open area um and a sniper has eyes on
you it's there's really nothing you can
can do about it unless you are going to
get up and just take a chance and run
for it crawling away slowly wouldn't
work he's just going to watch you crawl
and decide when to shoot anyway so it's
it's a lose lose this scene here I don't
think I worked that day so no I only
have so much control but this scene I
would rate like a oh my I'm doing this
to myself I'm going to give it a
five
I don't know if I be comfortable with
taking that shot through the the
windshield portion of a helicopter
bullets act funny when they hit objects
and the first object that bullet is
going to hit is that glass and because
it's curved it's going to deflect the
bullet up or down left or right there's
really no you know determining Factor on
as to where that bullet's going to land
at so one shot one kill for that
helicopter scene not so
much from underneath the car that's
actually a good thing to do I've shot
from underneath various vehicles and
structures and stuff like that
especially like in an urban environment
you're going to encounter so much debris
and Rubble on the battlefield or where
you're fighting from so you have to make
do with what you have the only issue was
like her hand placement on the rifle
like she already has the bipods I don't
see a need to have her hand underneath
it supporting it as well just extra
weight dangling for no reason I would
have probably had my uh support hand
closer or holding the buttstock into my
shoulder pocket as opposed to
that during sniper school we were always
told to call in an air strike when up
against another sniper CU it's really
tough to uh you know take out or fight
against I believe she's shooting like a
762 caliber round which is well within
the the capabilities of taking out a
Target at that distance the odds of it
being dead on at whatever range he was
would have meant that she would have had
to know that distance ahead of time and
kind of uh dial in her scope for that
instead she just stuck it on there and
pulled the trigger on the head it's not
really like that but other than that she
I think she did pretty good given the
circumstances I would have probably done
the same thing but I'd give it an eight
she looked really calm behind it and
some of the best snipers I know are
female
yeah so this movie is based off of an
actual sniper uh Miss pavlenko she was
credited with over 309 kills and as far
as putting that bullet through the tank
like that I don't know I've only aimed
at a tank one time and it was by
accident and I was quickly reminded
don't do that again when they point at
the big cannon my
way
she went into her bubble Carlos Hathcock
uh Marine Corp sniper called it getting
into his bubble that's what she's doing
when all these mortar shells and and
explosions are going off around her it's
getting into that bubble being able to
shut that outside world off of the chaos
and calming down and ignoring everything
to to pull off a shot I can relate to
that
110%
no so bullets don't travel in a straight
line like that they travel at an arc
even at 100 yards so to win that battle
you have to aim higher causing the
bullet to go up and a hit its apex point
and fall back down all snipers are just
like really good NFL quarterbacks he's
throwing it up and they're falling into
the Target and bullets work the same
exact way because it was based on a true
story
I'll give it a nine not a 10 just
because the bullet trajectory females
women make the best snipers out there no
sh abandoned selective targeting all
Targets are now free the distances he's
shooting from like that's very plausible
here it looks like he's maybe at most
150 100 yards away like less than that
cuz he's shooting down so less than 50
yards possibly the scope is not bad
either I'm used to like m dot Scopes and
Horus reticles and they look like busy
Christmas trees some you like without
the lights on inside of sniper Scopes it
was a very simple
reticle shooting in a crowded
environment is extremely tough during
the international sniper competition
that I attended that was one of the
challenges was to shoot moving targets
among a crowd it's extremely hard to do
but our distances were way further than
what he appears to be shooting by like a
lot at the angles he was you know he was
given and the distances it's not that
complicated just worrying about where
the bullet's going to hit after you hit
your target would be like my only
concern because they're in so close
proximity to each other has a
possibility of getting hit too I would
give it a solid eight uh it's highly
realistic
the Scopes are always messed up I don't
I don't understand why they just don't
put a real scope reticle in there so
this is a actual spotting scope similar
to what the individual the the snipers
using in the movie and he's using it
pretty correctly like he's using it for
Target detection to identify where a
threat may be he noticed a little bullet
on the ledge of that window and then you
know finding things that were out of
place that didn't make sense and
eventually finding where the sniper was
to something you see rare in movies the
actual use of Target detection and how
important it is for a sniper to find the
smallest details and things that are out
of place to find out you know find who
they're looking
for what you want to do is be pushed
back away from the hole and not put the
barrel protruding outside of the hole
gives your position away and alleviates
that that whole purpose of why you made
that hole in the first place I'll give
it a seven I love the use of Target
detection but he messed up putting
putting the barrel through the whole my
favorite sniper scene of all time would
have to be from the movie Lone Survivor
they had their sniper rifle and they
were engaging Targets in the woods and
that was like the most realistic wor
scene I have ever seen in my life thanks
for watching and if you like this video
be sure to aim at one of the videos
above and maybe give it a shot or
two